as usual with Excel it can be a bit
tricky keeping track of steps so I
advise between the two of you see you
next to each other maybe one of you pays
more attention to what's happening and
the other ones working out you know
actually what you're going to punch in I
will go back and do it but I can't do it
endlessly because otherwise we'll never
get anywhere okay
so the first thing we're going to create
is the table that we've started to build
we're just going to do it oh I forgot
this is a touchscreen well you're just
going to do it much more efficiently so
we need to start with an X and all I
thank you okay so let's do that I'm
gonna keep running around now so here's
an X and he's a Y guys well that was
bigger than I intended
okay let's try that again that's better
okay so we've got our X and our Y rows
that's a bit too wide I don't do it okay
now across the top we test our
particular values of X right I think we
had 0 1 2 3 4 & 5
yeah that's far we went okay now mm-hmm
the equation we were looking at was 2x
squared I'm actually gonna I told a lie
I'm gonna put this on the whiteboard
just because most of you don't have it
on the same screen
you've probably got on your page though
it was 2x squared was it - 4 X yeah
fantastic okay now watch carefully to
get our computer to do this to get our
spreadsheet to do this you need to use
some fancy symbols so the first thing
you going to do is say equals y is that
what does that do it's it's going to
calculate something because it's saying
this is an equation now it's going to be
equal to so I want two x squared so I'm
going to say 2 but remember 2x squared
is actually shorthand for 2 what
operation is hiding in there that we
don't say multiply right now there's no
multiplication symbol on your keyboard
so you need to go shift 8 and use the
asterisk okay now the next thing we want
is X but the whole idea is the X values
are these things at the top right so
instead of saying X I'm just
click on this cell up here right because
that's what my ex is for that value okay
now again I need to show you one more
face deceive on that's that's it to get
a power you've got no power button on
your calculator either sorry on your
keyboard so you need to press shift six
this has the very effective name called
that so this is a hat and it's to the
power of two so I know it looks weird
but what this means is two times x
squared or raised to the power of two I
can raise to the power of anything I
like but two is what I want okay
now that's not the whole thing I need
all the rest of the pieces right now
this is easier so I'm going to subtract
four times now what's next what do I do
here I'm gonna click on that cell
because that's X and then I'm gonna add
three okay let me leave that there for a
moment just so you can look at it no
Excel or anything that's why that's all
right have you got it there now at this
one you can now hit enter and hopefully
it should confirm for you the value that
we got before looking good okay so here
comes the magic now I'm not I don't dare
do it with my finger on here because I
don't think my aim will be good enough
but do you notice there's this tiny
little dot on the corner of yourself
there should be like a fatter green dot
I want you to click on that maybe I'll
try what's what's the most can happen I
want you to click on it and drag it over
okay something like this oh wait no no I
missed no no that's not it either
I just can't deal with the mouse okay so
I'm gonna click it and drag it over
because I want to complete the table and
voila okay
so if you're if you're no good with your
manual dexterity and you can't aim and
hit that like I can't of course the
other easy way is you just
yourselves and you just paste them
across okay just for the sake of it go
over to 19 which happens to my favorite
number and don't quit yeah so the
equation of course Shh stay with me at
all
it looks ever so familiar except for a
subtle difference there's the - there's
the squared there's the for there's the
multiplication what's different its f1
instead of being one because when we
moved across it carried the reference
with it so I was always looking at the
cell above which is exactly what we
wanted to do thumbs up so far correct so
we call these aren't relative references
okay okay now this is yes if you you
mean like how to get them across just
copy it and then paste it across that'll
that'll work for you just copy back okay
now it gets better it gets better so I'm
gonna zoom out a little bit what I want
you to now is to highlight your data
there and unfortunately you know
everyone's version of Excel is just ever
so slightly different in fact this is
different to the version I practiced on
but it should be the thing I'm looking
for shouldn't be too hard to find go up
to the insert tab right at the top
insert and you should be able to find
some graphs okay now the one I'm
interested in is the scatter plot do you
ever what scatter plots look like so I
think it's that set of dots there that's
really small on my older version of
Excel you just had to find the word
scatter plot so if I hit that you get
this shape okay now what I've got is the
points that should fit a problem you can
kind of sort of see it but we can do
better than sort of see it I want you to
right-click on one of these data points
anyone it should do right click on it ah
now do you remember back in ds2 5 or 6
oh I can't remember which one it was and
we were looking at lines of best fit do
you remember that so we had lines of
best because you had like a scatter plot
of data and you're like let's find it
and it goes all the way through but what
we didn't talk about back then is the
fact that we're not all Dada wants to be
a straight line this clearly doesn't
want to be a straight line so when you
go to add trendline over on the
right-hand side we didn't really talk
about this before because we only
worried out one kind of trendline namely
a straight one you can see on the
right-hand side you've got all these
options now a quadratic is a special
kind of equation in a broader family of
equations called polynomials do you see
polynomial over there now
what you can do is you can try different
ones but if you have a look at say well
that's obviously this straight line is
struggling a little bit if I put
exponential in there it's still not that
great but when you hit polynomial BAM
it's right on which shouldn't surprise
us because of course we made these data
points out of a pod R attic polynomial
okay ah so this is a quadratic which
means the power is two so you can change
the power you can make it higher because
polynomials have all different ones okay
now that was the first question okay
here's where uh they're still sorry
sorry I promise on my son doing come in
and wait or are you guys learning
something over there
okay I'll come and get you is that okay
thanks they've got marking queries okay
now um do you guys have your textbook
also there can you load it up if you
haven't already we're in 12a right okay
okay actually I'll write this up while
we're at it okay Shh okay get off
so in 12a the data points you just
created the table of values they
correspond to question one that's that's
question one okay
now before we leave it I want you to
have a look at the question now okay
have a look at what it asks you the
first thing is create the data so you
guys can now fill in that table in your
books using the fact that technology has
done the job for you okay but that's not
all it asks it says sketch the parabola
now we've used technology to help us but
you need to actually be able to draw
this on a piece of paper you're going to
need to draw the Cartesian plane want
any advantages you have is you can draw
it wherever you like this Cartesian
plane doesn't include everything what
kinds of things are missing from this
cartesian plane have a look carefully
look at the values is my clear there are
no negative values right can you see
over here on our Cartesian plane we know
it goes negative one negative two
negative I axis down here you guys can
draw that part you can have the the
relevant coordinates and the relevant
part of the graph there okay but there's
one last question have a look at the
actual question what it asks what does
it say papí see okay now this is really
important because you don't know
necessarily what that means
so put your pens down and look up for a
minute when we talk about the minimum
value I remember not to lean on this
because I keep highlighting things the
minimum value means what is the lowest
this thing can possibly go
okay so lowest not like leftmost or
right worst so we're looking for this Y
value here now the Y now you can read
off of this table okay so there it is
you would say the minimum value of this
is one okay but you get different
functions you get
kinds of behavior so now that you know
what this is going to be you can go
ahead and you can draw it in your own
time but let's just quickly modify this
this is the beauty of spreadsheets we
only need to modify a few things to make
everything work for a new question